привіт Я Андрій Кравець я покинув офісну
кар'єру і ризикнув займатися роботою
мрії
Як усе було ну 15 років Я пропрацював
експедитором у великій компанії
влаштувався туди ще студентом а потім
Доріс до керівника відділу я розвивався
але рідко відчував натхнення думав вже
так буде завжди я хотів знаю Свободи
Одного разу я купив за довгих брюки і
вирішив їх підшити Ага сам шви були
кривенькі але за довгий час я вперше
відчув задоволення від процесу Так я
почав шити
[музика]
Спочатку я шукав ескізи в інтернеті
хотів навчити сам але швидко зрозумів
щоб стати професіоналом потрібно
допомога тому я пройшов в курсі для
дорослих в одному зі швейних училищ
навчався ввечері після роботи Так це
було важко іноді думав чи справді вона
того варте але в мене вийшло спочатку
робимо для знайомих набивав в руку зараз
в мене багато клієнтів допомогли
соціальній мережі люди Їх бачать мої
роботи хвалять І я відчуваю себе
корисним звісно Останнім часом я шию
багато військового спорядження ледве
встигаю якщо чесно Але до мене
звертається із приводу чогось знаєте
звичного піджаки штани плаття
така довжина подобається Чи коротша
подобається
гарно виглядати в такий час допомагає
людям треба бути собою і бути таким яким
ти собі подобаєшся який важкі часи не
були
тож Роблю все щоб життя продовжувалося і
все було як треба